hours from right now the house committee
on January 6 is expected to vote on
recommending criminal charges against
former president Trump for his alleged
role in the capital attack there are a
wide range of potential offenses that
could be on the table today including
Insurrection although we do stress that
these would be recommendations for the
justice department not official charges
CBS news also has exclusive reporting
from Robert Costa audio from a key
witness but we're going to go first to
Scott McFarland who's on Capitol Hill
he's been following all this for weeks
and months now Scott Good morning Tony
good morning to you source is familiar
with the committee's planning say votes
on criminal referrals against former
president Trump or expected midday at
this final public meeting of the house
elect January 6 committee the possible
charges to be referred would be
obstruction of an official proceeding
conspiracy and over the weekend one
Committee Member discussed the
possibility of a charge of incitement of
an Insurrection that's a charge that
hasn't been brought against the 900 plus
defendants charged so far in the riot
the panel has completed more than one
thousand interviews CBS News has learned
they've collected more than one million
documents a criminal referral though is
not binding on the justice department
it's just that a recommendation but this
weekend Committee Member Adam Schiff
argued there is enough evidence to
Warrant charges enough evidence to
charge Donald Trump today the committee
releases its executive summary of its
findings later this week they'll issue
their full written report and
transcripts of all their interviews with
their Witnesses CBS News has learned
that'll include transcripts of
interviews with Ivanka Trump Jared
Kushner and Rudy Giuliani Gail
all right got it Scott thank you